Okay I'm really excited because we just got our 23 me results back and
Joanna's actually going to walk us through the
results. Joanna what do we do first?
>> Well let's go and log in, and then we
get to choose to look at health results first or ancestry
results and I typically like to look at someone's ancestry
results first because that really gives us context for the rest.
>> Okay let's go do that. Okay, Joanna I just pulled up the page.
>> Right. Okay, so the first thing we do, Matt, is, is sign
in here, if you want to click up here.
>> Okay.
>>
>> Al right, let me put in my login information.
>> Yep, great.
And there are a bunch of options for where to
start here but, I suggest we start with ancestry overview. And.
>> Okay
>> I suggest we, the, that most a broad overview
of your ancestry is in this feature called ancestry composition
and we can already tell from this that eh, about
a quarter of your ancestry traces back to Britain and Ireland.
>> Oh great so we'll click right here then.
>> Yep, yep. And this
is what we call a ring chart, this is Matt Cook's ring chart and let's
get a little more detail by clicking the Plus sign there. And if you click it
one more time, that's when we get down to the level of the, of Britain
and Ireland, that the one quarter British and
Irish is indicated by that blue ring there.
>> Mm-hm
>> and so overall your ancestry
traces to Northern Europe just like me.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And, if you look, that's where most of your ancestry traces to close
to 98% traces to northern Europe and nothing, I don't see
anything tracing to southern Europe. But one curious thing, if you click
right here on Sub-Saharan Africa, there's, that just, just less than a percent
of your ancestry traces back to, to Africa, and that, what I want to do
is look at where on your genome that segment that traces back to Africa is.
>> Okay.
>> So, we're now looking at, this is the ring
chart view, let's go and change from the map view.
>> Okay.
>> To the chromosome view.
>> Chromosome view?
>> Yes.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And so we see that if we looked
at chromosome, so each of these pairs of bars is
a pair of chromosomes and, and we've heard
throughout the course about pairs of chromosomes coming from
mother and father. So that's what we're looking at
here we start with the longest chromosome, number one.
>> Mm hm.
>> Number two is next and we go all the way
down to chromosome 22, and then the X chromosome here, is here.
>> And I only have one.
>> You only have one which is indicative of
you being male, which I think you already knew that.
>> I already knew that.
That's good.
>> But its always nice when your DNA
results are consistent with something you already know.
>> Sure.
>> That is kind of a check. It's something
we actually check, we ask all the customers to
tell us if they're male or female, and then we look at their DNA to see if it
[INAUDIBLE].
That just helps us know that these are really all your data.
>> Great.
>> And what I, I was curious about was this red strip here so what we can
see most of those bars, the chromosomes are a
shade of blue and that indicates ancestry from Europe.
>> hum
>> Or, or Britain or Ireland. Now but there's
there's some other colors here and the red refers to
Sub-Saharan African ancestry which of the chromosomes seems to
have at least a segment tracing back to Africa?